good job at the bow sweat now piece well
you got to be the dude ain't gonna burn
my truck I'm going
that
if fallout has taught us anything is
that you managed to rebuild itself the
world ever come to a nuclear end we'd
like to think that we'd rise from the
ashes of a stable and steady system of
governments and laws but what's more
likely is the world will split to a
collection of factions ranging from the
relatively sane all the way down to team
we love eating people still it's better
than going in alone
with that in mind here's a rundown of
the major factions in the world of
Fallout and what you may see in fallout
4 sometimes the best things are born out
of horror when US military captain Roger
Maxson discovers scientists at his base
with performing experimental mutations
on live prisoners in October 2077 he
wasn't too pleased and he was less of a
have a stern word than he was execute
the more sort of man but unfortunately
for Roger the bombs fell three days
later and he and his soldiers what I
stranded in what was left of
civilization
so Roger decided to make the best of a
bad situation he set up a headquarters
for the newly formed brotherhood of
steel in the government fallout shelter
Lost Hills he appointed himself high
elder Maxon and began his mission to
rebuild civilization by eradicating
mutants and preserving worthwhile
technology and knowledge for future
generations
you think the Brotherhood would realize
the key to mankind's revival would be an
education and agricultural technology
but they were soldiers not farmers so
they filled their space Ark with energy
weapons and power armor instead over
time the Brotherhood fractured across
the wasteland becoming paranoid and
xenophobic in their isolation sharing
secrets and tech was deemed treason and
Outsiders were shunned their role in
Fallout 4 is unclear but the prominence
of vertibirds and power armor and
trailers suggests they may still have
some weight to throw around the Enclave
of the wastelands Illuminati before
Earth got its nuclear tan they were a
secret faction of politicians military
officials and industrialists operating
as a secret shadow government in between
throwing bundles of money each other and
cackling at peasants these rich lands
were hoarding dwindling resources hiding
and bunkers and planning what would
eventually become the vault experiments
like all isolated rich elitists the
enclave believed that the last bastion
of pure humanity and think wastelanders
as abominations unfortunately they've
also got lots of fancy robots vertibirds
power armor and the
forced evolutionary virus still you
showed them what for in Fallout 2 where
as the chosen one you crashed a tanker
into their headquarters destroyed their
seat of power and scattered them across
the wasteland some of them fled to the
east which means we could see them in
fallout 4 but whether they will be
anything like the political and
scientific powerhouse of old is yet to
be seen
from the moment you see a two-headed
bear on the flag you know you're in for
a good time with the NCR California's
only place for bears with more than one
head founded in Fallout shady sands and
muddled on the pre-war government the
new California Republic are a
surprisingly well-mannered ordered and
distinctly not crazy faction at least in
comparison to the ones that crucify
people worship bombs and dress up like
Elvis extra points for having a
relatively high standard of living for a
world infested with three-foot
cockroaches they've had a handful of
presidents over the course of their
existence but you won't be seeing them
anywhere near the White House as they're
pretty comfortable taking over the West
Coast for now you're probably better off
for it too given that the current
incarnation of the NCR are a rather
belligerent lot with more beef than a
hamburger factory regardless of this
their reputation still carries influence
across the wasteland let's be honest if
you were going to create a crazed
power-hungry cult in a dusty irradiated
wasteland you'd probably based on the
Romans to prose you get to call yourself
Kaiser you get to enslave loads of
people to do on your work your followers
slash slaves are all fanatically devoted
to you as a result all that brainwashing
you did and you occasionally get to
speak Latin the best language of all our
way amicus cons your fame is built on
the back of slaves one of your favorite
hobbies is crucifying people and you
consider women to be subhuman hmm
founded by Edward sallow and Joshua
Graham a couple of religious
wastelanders kaisers legion was intended
to unite humanity under a regime of
military training Salo convinced his
followers the atomic bomb was sent by
the god Mars renamed himself Caesar and
set about enslaving conscripting and
crucifying his way across the mojave to
this day Caesar and his happy bunch of
indentured captors roam the land
marauding at every opportunity we
probably won't see them in Fallout 4
given that a base of operations is the
west coast and it's really hard to walk
several hundred miles in gladiator
sandals but what would an episode of the
fallout 4 show be without a bit of
speculation
talk about the factions we could
potentially see in fallout 4 the
Institute is what remains the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology a
place to house the most talented
scientists at the United States although
we know that mr. house there's a premie
powerful business magnate and father of
new Vegas with the gross desiccated
nearly dead body used to be a member of
the Institute back when he looked more
like a person rather than beef jerky
with a face the most important thing to
know about the Institute is that they
possess the ability to create androids
with artificial intelligence who believe
themselves to be human and to enslave
them the railroad the second of the two
rumored factions works in opposition to
the Institute seeking to free the
sentient androids from their oppressive
creators and masters given that fallout
4 takes place in the Commonwealth where
Boston is where in both railroad and
Institute territory and there are loads
of rumors flying around about whether or
not you're an Android our room is true
not long to wait until we can find out